[Applauso]
Buonasera a tutti a tutte Grazie per
essere qui così numerosi per condividere
delle strade per i nostri sogni quando
mi hanno detto che il tema sarebbe stato
possibile utopie ho avuto la tentazione
di non accettare perché mi capita spesso
non so a voi A volte mi sento troppo
piccola per i temi Sfidanti dei nostri
giorni o comunque mi sento come se fosse
stato già detto e proposto tutto poi mi
sono detta che forse non c'era migliore
occasione di questa per raccontare
qualcosa appunto che tengo nel cuore e
che in qualsiasi altro contesto mi
avrebbe fatto passare per la salita
idealista e quindi Eccomi qua sono
partita dalla sostenibilità Perché si
parla di sostenibilità tanto e
giustamente in ogni ambito e così mi
sono chiesta c'è un modo per rendere il
nostro mondo interiore la nostra anima
sostenibile sostenibile in ogni senso
nel senso di
non nociva quindi benefica e leggera
leggera per noi stessi e per gli altri e
mi sono detta che questa era proprio la
mia utopia possibile cercare una strada
per questo scopo
combinando vari risorse a partire da
quelle che appunto riguardano
prettamente il mio lavoro ed è di questo
che voglio parlarvi stasera di disarmo
interiore di cosa voglia dire per me e
di come secondo me possiamo arrivarci
tutti insieme recuperando diciamo una
condizione di leggerezza e di
consapevolezza che ci permetta di
trasformare queste armi in strumenti
disarmo per me non è ricerca della
perfezione assolutamente È perché le
barriere che comunque Costruiamo nella
nostra vita che innalziamo sono delle
protezioni e quindi essendo delle
protezioni hanno qualcosa da dirci su di
noi quindi ben vengano ben vengano però
se sappiamo ascoltarle se riusciamo ad
percepire quello che che hanno da dirci
Ecco così che riusciamo proprio a
trasformarle da barriere a risorse
saranno un dono e non un peso per noi
stessi e per evolvere come società Sono
partita dalla mia storia e mi sono
chiesta Quando ho iniziato io ad armarmi
è stato sorprendente diciamo il fatto di
dover andare molto indietro nel tempo
vengo da una famiglia meravigliosa dove
amore e sostegno non sono mai mancati
però nonostante questo sin dalla prima
adolescenza fino a Dopo l'università
ho vissuto con un costante senso di
inadeguatezza non mi riconoscevo in
niente e in nessuno e sentivo che il
mondo che mi stava intorno non mi
apparteneva
era molto difficile perché mi piacevano
cose che non piacevano agli altri e non
desideravo quello che gli altri
desideravano Insomma sulle strade
battute dagli altri io non ero felice e
la frustrazione cresceva nel non
riuscire a dare una direzione alla mia
Ho riletto delle pagine di diario di
quando facevo le medie e le superiori e
ho potuto toccare con mano un dolore
molto importante vi devo praticamente ai
margini di ciò che mi circondava
aspettando che arrivasse il mio posto
nel mondo ho toccato una sofferenza
veramente grande e mi sono riconnessa
con quella fatica che Avevo rimosso però
ha lavorato dentro sicuramente e mi
rendo conto che soltanto quando ho
iniziato poi dopo l'università a pensare
all'arte come una possibile via
lavorativa mi sono appunto Cominciate a
riconoscere in qualcosa iniziando a
studiare sollecitazione teatro
attraverso i primi esercizi propedeutici
ho cominciato a gestire e a conoscere le
mie emozioni a capire di più sul mio
vissuto a guardarlo con occhi nuovi a
risolvere dei traumi e tutto piano piano
ha cominciato a rimettersi a posto e io
ho cominciato a guardare consapevolmente
dentro me stessa è stata la prima volta
E lì ho iniziato a dare un nome ai miei
bisogni questo processo stupendo è stato
ed è tuttora la base del mio lavoro e
quindi mi sento una privilegiata questo
questo aspetto di gestione delle
emozioni appunto uno degli aspetti
fondamentali insieme alla consapevolezza
del proprio vissuto che poi si scelga o
meno di inserirlo nella costruzione di
un personaggio questo è un altro
discorso ci sono varie scuole di
pensiero e molto diciamo dipende anche
da quello che si va a raccontare e a
fare ma insomma questo è l'aspetto
basilare un altro aspetto fondamentale è
quello di radicarsi nel precedente per
regalare al pubblico qualcosa di genuino
di vero bisogna stare con il proprio
compagno di scena in senso emotivo e
anche in senso fisico quindi avere
consapevolezza del proprio corpo nello
spazio consapevolezza dello spazio
stesso e consapevolezza dell'altro nello
spazio Inoltre essendo il mio campo
piuttosto sfidante Perché diciamo ti
espone a un giudizio continuo per sua
stessa natura mi sono diciamo trovata ad
approfondire molto l'argomento che
riguarda tutto il mondo della formazione
quindi passando dallo studio del
linguaggio e comunicazione tutto questo
ha avuto un impatto sulla mia vita
lavorativa Ma anche sulla mia vita
personale
e quindi mi sono chiesta Ma se io non
avessi dovuto per imparare le basi le
prime basi di un mestiere non avessi
dovuto approcciare a tutti questi
strumenti a tutti questi temi
io non sarei venuta in contatto con
tutto ciò che mi ha permesso di
togliermi di dosso questa sensazione di
disagio questa sensazione di
inadeguatezza
Quindi praticamente viviamo in una
società che
legittima o giustifica un tempo di
ricerca personale solo se questo ha uno
scopo lavorativo e performativo
guardandomi intorno poi anche andando
avanti con gli anni e conoscendo sempre
più persone e andando un po' oltre
quello che era il mio piccolo mondo
adolescenziale mi sono resa conto che in
fondo tutti vivono momenti di
smarrimento nella vita o di mancanza di
consapevolezza e mi sono chiesta se
tutti questi strumenti fossero
disponibili sin dall'infanzia e
venissero studiati teatro e recitazione
in ogni scuola di ordine grado Beh
sicuramente Qualcuno potrebbe dirmi che
in molti paesi c'è diciamo un'educazione
teatrale valida e non per questo ci sono
società con individui consapevoli ed è
assolutamente così per questo voglio
spingermi oltre nella mia utopia e per
me si dovrebbe partire dagli esercizi
propedeutici del teatro per poi andarli
a combinare una volta tolto diciamo
l'aspetto performativo andarli a
combinare con tutta un'altra serie di
discipline lo studio del linguaggio di
come funzioniamo degli ormoni nel nostro
corpo
tutta una serie di discipline correlate
che vadano a fare da supporto per la
creazione Non lo so di una nuova materia
che potrebbe chiamarsi
teatro e interazione umane Arti e
scienze umane Ecco impareremo a metterci
nei panni di un personaggio Quindi nei
panni dell'altro ma conoscendo il nostro
Spazio Interiore useremo l'empatia in
modo equilibrato Insomma secondo me si
limiterebbero di molto
gli accumuli di frustrazioni e di difese
e magari se le persone fossero sin
dall'infanzia guidate in questo processo
in età adolescenziale verrebbe più
naturale
proseguire con questa ricerca e si
userebbe l'adolescenza non come un
momento così che prima o poi passa un
momento di passaggio ma come il momento
dei momenti perché le energie degli
adolescenti sono inesauribili
meravigliose e Bisognerebbe sfruttarle
si potrebbe dare loro la possibilità di
illuminare in modo concreto la loro
strada e magari renderli già pubblico
critico e consapevole del fatto teatrale
come fatto sociale
mi sono chiesta Ma se gli individui
fossero più felici del loro percorso
cambierebbe forse il modo in cui
guarderebbero l'altro
cambierebbe il modo in cui guarderebbero
la società
se fossimo più integrati con il mondo
che ci circonda
Saremmo pronti a fare scelte più
consapevoli per pianeta
cioè invece di avere adulti che cercano
modi di dare aria a bambini interiori
soffocati non sarebbe meglio
accompagnarli nella crescita affinché
non debbano perdersi mai
Ecco mi sono detta che poteva non essere
un desiderio solo mio
voi come vi sentireste se vi avessero
insegnato sin da bambini
a legittimare e comprendere tutte le
vostre emozioni
forse avresti vissuto più anni
all'altezza dei vostri reali bisogni
Ecco A volte anche io soffro per il
tempo perso per la mia realizzazione che
a volte mi sembra perso Però ognuno poi
nella vita fa quello che può con gli
strumenti che ha su un momento e quindi
bando e rimpianti
cosa vorrei cosa Vorrei che faceste
adesso mi piacerebbe che voi andaste
tutti a iscrivervi a un corso di teatro
usciti da qui
però so che potrebbe non essere diciamo
la cosa più immediata che vi viene da
fare e allora Vi propongo delle cose
delle cose che possono partire
dal vostro mondo quotidiano proprio da
adesso adesso ci sarà l'intervallo per
esempio no vi faccio vi lascio una sfida
allora alla fila per andare in bagno vi
troverete Insomma faccia a faccia uno
accanto all'altro Provate a guardarvi
Provate a togliere il cellulare a
guardarvi negli occhi non ci sarà
bisogno di dire niente cercate di
donarvi all'altro di sentire cosa
l'altro può donare a voi
quando uscite tornate a casa sentite il
vostro corpo nello spazio
siate consapevoli di ciò che vi circonda
delle persone che vi passano accanto
Insomma piccoli atti di disarmo
quotidiani che vadano a richiamare gli
aspetti del teatro di cui abbiamo
parlato prima quindi consapevolezza
presenza per se stessi e per gli altri
Insomma mi piacerebbe che l'impatto
sulle vostre stesse vite sulle nostre
stesse vite e su quelli degli altri
fossero di valore fossero
sostenibili e mi piacerebbe tanto che
questo fosse il fulcro dell'insegnamento
nel sistema educativo Io ho provato a
immaginare solo una strada Ecco che
possa diciamo farci compiere questa
magia di trasformazione magari barriera
dopo barriera Resistenza dopo Resistenza
credo che se è vero che nessuno si salva
da solo
sarete d'accordo con me nel dire che
nessuno può essere utile alla società e
al bene comune se non conosce e ama
profondamente il proprio valore la
propria missione e se non può mostrarsi
al mondo disarmato Grazie a tutti e buon
disarmo
[Applauso]